when judd apatow was here he told me
that great story about you guys pitching
mick jagger the movie about the rolling
stones that the two of you went
and visited
and said to mick jagger hey we want to
do a movie with you where we're like two
guys who follow you around i think we're
gonna be you and brad pitt brad pitt
we're gonna i thought it was the
greatest that you actually got a meeting
with mick jagger pitched him an id loved
it and then keith richards killed the
whole [ __ ] deal
he didn't like it first of all mick was
calling
right because his producing partner
victoria pearman had uh reached out to
us i think she'd seen maybe the ben
stiller show or something
uh and she was saying hey mick has this
idea and then so like just to have mick
pitch us on the call about what he
wanted to do and and then
then the sort of the catch was that we
had to pitch the rolling stones so like
nick got us on board then it was like
but you got to get everybody else on
board
uh and then we went to toronto and uh
they were rehearsing in i think it was a
girls school or something in the
gymnasium wow and yeah and we got to sit
and watch them uh rehearse for like an
hour well before
how [ __ ] nervous were you like
talking to keith richards about and
trying to convince charlie watts that
you know hey we're gonna i just remember
i don't i don't remember a lot of it
honestly because it was so overwhelming
except that we were in a small
like wood-paneled room like an
anti-chamber sort of like room off of
the you know gym
and they were all sitting there kind of
huddled around and uh
you know and just i remember just kind
of looking back trying to pitch and i
didn't i'm not good at pitching stuff
i'm really right
and
you know and i was trying to tell them
how funny it would be and you know even
just the idea of like comedy and rock
and roll like a like i don't think you
know would anybody really want to see
the funny fans like the super fan guys
who are like crawling up on the lighting
pant you know the the rigging to like
try to get close to the the band and
then like falling behind the back like
the idea probably wouldn't have worked
you know
in execution because people would have
just wanted to see a rolling stones
concert film exactly
who wants to see two guys whether it's
you and brad pitt or anybody i want to
see the stones if i'm watching his stone
exactly right you're going to see a
comedy you see a comedy you can see a
concert movie you see a concert movie
but maybe it was mick's idea of like
reacting to the beatles and in his sense
of history with help and hard day's
night like maybe he was looking at it
and he's a real we could do something
yeah he's a real film guy i mean like he
really you know he's an actor and so
like you know who knows if maybe it
would have worked wouldn't the movie be
great if the movie was just you pitching
keith richards about a movie
as a 26 year old kid you're sitting
there going this is what it is yeah and
you don't even know what it is you're
right exactly
it didn't exist